insomniaque du val de loire ces cinq
prochaines minutes sont pour vous vous
êtes 20% à souffrir du manque de sommeil
mauvais réflexe à perdre et solutions
pour mieux dormir on voit ça avec mon
invité à l'occasion de la journée
internationale du sommeil bonsoir
docteur au du mot commun la journée
c'est vous êtes somnologue c'est-à-dire
médecins spécialistes du sommeil avant
de penser de parler conseille d'abord on
a envie de savoir est ce que le
confinement à dégrader notre sommeil
oui tout à fait et nous on a noté une
augmentation surtout de troubles du
sommeil à type d'insomnie
donc soit des difficultés à s'endormir
ou alors dd maintien ça fait expliquer
aussi évidemment dans le contexte
anxiogène et puis aux commandes il ya
plus d'exposition aux écrans et ça c'est
assez néfaste pour la mélatonine hormone
du sommeil est évidemment moins
d'activité physique
on avait le droit à 60 minutes mais tout
le monde n'a pas exploité et donc tous
ces éléments ont fait que oui les
troubles de sommeil ont augmenté mais
surtout les infirmiers les autres
troupes sont assez stables
insomnie c'est une deux trois heures de
sommeil en moins c'est quoi non en fait
c'est si on savoir du mal c'est
subjectif en fait savoir du mal soit
sans dormir soit être réveillés au
milieu de nuit soit réveillé avant le
réveil on peut avoir un deux ou les
trois insomnie chronique c'est trois
nuits comme ça en fait pendant plus de
trois mois avec des conséquences en
journée alors on va passer à
l'application concrète avec ce un petit
quiz
ce qu'il faut se forcer à se coucher tôt
pour être reposé il faut surtout à
écouter ces signaux sommeil est allé se
coucher quand on les a dessinés au
sommeil ils sont propres à chacun le
classique les jeux bail chez les yeux
qui piquent etc mais surtout faut pas
imposer un horaire c'est l'horaire de
lever qui est fixe mais avoir deux
couches et plus il faut plutôt écouter
mais alors si on se réveille avec la
sensation d'avoir mal dormi vous parliez
de subjectivité un tout à l'heure est ce
que ça veut dire que ça ça a vraiment
été le cas en fait non non on peut avoir
bien dormi malgré tout oui tout à fait
et souvent d'ailleurs quand on a des
insomnies en personne encore moins bien
son sommeil donc c'est pour ça que nous
pour l'insomnie ont fait pas
d'enregistrement du sommeil puisque on
minore souvent son temps de sommeil
puisque travaille aussi à l'hôpital on a
fait une nuit blanche ou quasiment
est-ce que la journée sera forcément
compliqué non pas du tout c'est une
bonne note
s'en sortir oui tout à fait je pense que
les gens qui sont mariées ou qui ont eu
la remise d'un diplôme non pas une super
nuit et en fait c'était une belle
journée poids oui pourquoi pas ce qu'on
trouvera les ressources finalement parce
qu'on a toujours des ressources
exactement qui est parfois encore une
fois on on croit qu'on dort moins que ce
qu'on a fait en réalité et puis en fait
sur une nuit on parlait des marathons de
tours souvent la veille du marathon les
coureurs ils dorment patin mais c'est ok
la question des médicaments alors est-ce
que ça aide ou pas non on n'aime pas du
tout nouveau les médecins du sommeil
alors en très ponctuelle sur un choc ou
un trauma oui on peut effectivement mais
sur les insomnies chroniques pas du tout
un temps il ya plein d'autres ressources
et à ceux dont on a parlé qui sont
effectivement arrêter les écrans
augmenter l'activité physique mais la
sophrologie hypnose to date avait dit
c'est ça c'est la partie conseil du coup
donc de l'exercice physique au moins 30
minutes sort non les gardes face en
ouais ouais
non pas que c'était si on osait
cessation de sortir les écrans les états
à partir de hockey l'heure alors en fait
la mélatonine à mais une heure et demie
est arrivé entre le moment là exactement
à la fée du sommeil montrant le moment
où la lumière bleue s'arrête et le
moment elles commencent à arriver donc
vous calculez votre horaire
habituellement fournissement parce qu'on
se rendort souvent effectivement à la
même heure quand même et vous faites
moins une heure et demi donc souvent ça
vers 21h un dernier conseil peut-être
pour bien dormir a toujours s'endormir
réconcilier faire un temps calme et oui
et se coucher horaire régulier ça c'est
important aussi bas surtout s'écouter et
voilà un profiter des moments
tranquilles la lecture le maquettisme
les mandalas une dernière question
peut-être sur l'air du temps pourquoi
certains estiment encore ça sert à rien
de dormir et pourquoi on glorifie
finalement le petit dormeur un certain
président dort peu la nuit et voilà on
en fait quelqu'un de très intelligent
alors pourquoi il ya eu d'autres un très
intelligent comme napoléon churchill qui
étaient des courts dormeurs en fait on a
besoin d'un temps de semaine qui nous
est propre
c'est génétique un chalet besoin de
beaucoup de temps de sommeil est en fait
surtout s'écouter parce que là on
glorifie parce qu'on est dans une
société de consommation qui vont nous
amener à restreindre ce qu'on appelle le
jet lag sociales sont essayés de de se
coucher le plus tard possible pour
profiter etc
mais en fait petit moyen grand dormeur
on réussit pas
et donc surtout s'écouter merci beaucoup
du mot commun de ces conseils sur le
sommeil